hi everyone my name is Brooks I am a
platform engineer at github we're the
team that I'm on works on our api's and
web hooks and today in the theme of
developer happiness I'd like to talk
about optimizing api's for consumers
with graph QL but before we dive into
graph QL let's start with api's and more
specifically rest api's I'm curious by a
show of hands how many of you have
written code that consumes a REST API
awesome cool how many of you have
written your own REST API
dang awesome cool and how many of you
before today have heard of graph QL dang
that's amazing ok awesome
so throughout today's talk I'd like to
use this particular API as a point of
reference this is an API that I put
together about a year ago and it's a
wrapper around an NYC open data set for
health inspections of restaurants here
in New York City and for anyone who's
just visiting New York City for the
conference basically whenever you walk
into a restaurant they're required to
post their letter grade their health
rating sorry the the letter grade of the
last inspection that they received and
so when looking at a REST API
specifically a request for a request for
a REST API there's a few components to
it the first is an HTTP verb or method
and that specifies the operation that
we'd like to take against the API and
the second is an endpoint which is an
identifier that allows us to specify the
part of the API that we'd like to
interact with so if we execute this
request we'll get back a response that
looks like this in this particular case
this API returns back JSON and it's
comprised of resources so if we take a
look at what one of those resources
might look like we can see that there's
a few components to the response the
first are attributes these are things
like the name the address of the
restaurant the cuisine that has been
categorized as and in some cases you'll
also see hyper media and hyper media is
a machine-readable link to another place
in the API about information related to
the resource so you can see on the
bottom there we have inspections URL and
if we follow that link we can get more
information about the inspections that
the
first restaurant has received in this
case we have a new resource that we're
dealing with so if we execute that
request you'll notice that we get again
attributes and more hypermedia and if we
follow this link this is all of the
violations that they received during a
given inspection so again as we make
these more requests we can build the
full picture of data that we as clients
may need in order to build an
application we execute that request
again we get back some attributes in
some hypermedia
but if you imagine us as a desktop
application you can see that it takes
numerous requests for us to determine
the information that we may need as a
client right we have to make numerous
HTTP requests in order to get all the
info that we need and this is especially
painful when you're working with say a
mobile client which might be working off
a super slow connection so rest api's
are optimized around servers and not
necessarily clients they're modeled
around the resources that they return
which makes them general-purpose and
reusable from client to client and
honestly that's one of rests biggest
strengths but the question that I posed
to us as API designers everyone who
raised your hand just now if you've
written a REST API is what if we wanted
to put our clients first what if we
wanted a better developer experience for
the people that are consuming these
api's so one in one pattern for that is
Baden's for front ends it was something
that was popularized by Netflix and
reused commonly and the general idea is
for each particular device that accesses
say Netflix is API they have their own
separate endpoint the only thing is this
can become a little bit problematic when
you have to start to deal with like deep
pagination for example if you have a
complex object relationship that gets
returned in this one endpoint it can be
really hard to have to iterate over all
of the different say restaurants and all
of their inspections and all of their
violations and this could be even harder
when you have to iterate on that
endpoint say that there's a new device
that was released a new Apple TV that
has a fancy new version of the Netflix
application the older devices that
haven't been updated end up getting all
of this new information that they not
may not be using
and this also only really works if you
as the API designer are in control of
the client and you completely understand
the data requirements that that client
may need and what about in the case of a
public API where you may not know
anything about the data requirements of
your clients well that's where graph QL
comes in it's a data query language for
your API so think of it as sequel which
is the lowest common denominator between
technologies like my sequel Postgres MS
sequel and think of it less as neo4j
which is an entire craft datastore in
its own right so graph QL is a query
language specification it's been
implemented in a variety of different
languages like Ruby JavaScript Python
and so on and the language was
originally created by Facebook to help
with the data access needs of their
mobile clients so here's the hello world
of graph QL you'll notice right off the
bat that it bears some resemblance to
JSON it almost looks like it's JSON but
without any of the values and that's
very much on purpose and we'll see why
in a few so there's a few different
components to a graph QL query the first
shown here is what we call a selection
set and me represents the currently
authenticated user and for the currently
authenticated user ID like to fetch the
first name last name and email we call
these fields so if you execute this
query against a graph QL server you'll
get back a response that looks like this
in this case again it's JSON and you'll
notice that the query defines the
structure of the response and that's a
really important part to graph QL so
going back to our NYC restaurant grades
example we still have an HTTP verb and
we still have an endpoint but that's
pretty much where the similarities with
rest
end and the reason that we have to use
an HTTP POST is because the client has
to send information to the server in
this case it's the the query that we
would like the server to execute so if
we look at an example for this
particular API you can see that this
looks a little bit like the hello world
example but we're now talking about
restaurants and there's a new concept
here in graph QL called an argument
we're basically saying I'd like to fetch
the name of a restaurant called cafe Gia
and an argument as a way for us to pass
eleven information to the server and
that way there the server can modify the
response based on the information that
we're looking for so if we execute this
again we get a response that's very much
structured like the query so let's take
a look at some of the features of the
query language the first is that graph
QL is typed and the type system is a
product of your application code so if
we look back to the original hello world
example behind the scenes there's
actually a schema and it's the schema
that graph QL is querying we call this
an IDL you can think of it as a database
schema but instead of describing the
structure of your database we're
describing the structure of what we can
query so if we break down this query we
can see that each part has a
corresponding entry in the schema the
first is me which returns a user type
which is defined down there below the
user type implements three fields first
name last name and email all of which
return what we call a scalar value it's
just a plain old string so if we look
back to our NYC restaurant grades
example here's the corresponding schema
for it breaking down each part of this
schema we can see that it starts with
the top-level restaurant right there
which takes an argument a name of string
and what's really neat about having a
type system in place with graph QL is
that you can determine whether or not a
query is valid right off the bat if
someone sends to you anything other than
a string for this named argument we know
that we can just fail the request and
say no sorry I don't support that and
the restaurant type which is defined
down below returns both a name and a
cuisine both of which are string but
you'll notice that there is a bang next
to the name entry that is basically with
a way of denoting that you will always
get back a value for that it's non
knowable but what if we wanted to return
a list of objects well in this
particular case we can use restaurants
plural which is something that this
particular API supports and you'll
notice that the argument here is
different from the previous example
where we have Brooklyn and all caps and
this query is utilizing a graph QL
feature called an enum an enum is a way
to specify a list of possible values so
if we look
the corresponding schema for this we can
see at the topmost level we return
restaurants which take in an argument of
restaurant borough and what's nice about
an enum is that we can specify exactly
what's supported it doesn't make sense
for this particular application to take
anything other than these five boroughs
and then finally we return a list of
restaurants each of which has a field
name and cuisine so what if we wanted to
fetch two restaurants by their name you
can imagine that the response would look
something like this right because the
query defines the shape of the response
but you'll notice that we have a key
conflict which I'm pretty sure is legal
JSON but would totally wreck havoc in
Ruby and so what graph Kuehl allows us
to do is alias field names and they can
be used to rename a particular subset of
the query to something else so if we
look at what this may look like as a
response you can see that instead of
having our duplicated restaurant field
names now they're using the alias field
names and one more thing that you'll
notice about that previous example is
that there's some duplication which
isn't great name and cuisine is reused
well what graph Kuehl allows us to do is
create what's called a fragment so down
on the bottom we define a fragment we
call it restaurant info and you have to
specify which type that it's defined on
now once you have the fragment we can
define what the things that we'd like to
fetch in this case name and cuisine and
then we've reused that fragment with
this dot dot dot notation towards the
top now another point in part to graph
QL is that it's introspect able meaning
that graph QL is capable of telling you
all of the different things that it can
that it's capable of returning and that
means that things like documentation and
client generation come for free now one
tool that utilizes the power of that of
the type system my introspection is
graphical which God willing I would like
to live demo so this is the part where I
ask that everyone make like a silent
prayer that this live demo goes well all
right so let's see this working cool
everybody see that
so this is graphical there's two main
parts to it on the left hand side we can
craft a query on the right hand side we
can see what the response would be I'm
just pointing this to a local rail
server that I have running and let's
give it a shot so let's say we want to
fetch a particular restaurant so you'll
notice as I start typing that graphical
offers like Clippy like suggestions and
that's because it's reusing the power of
introspection because the graphical
server is capable of telling us all of
the different things that it can query
it knows ahead of time in its context
aware so based on where my cursor is it
can offer suggestions so I'll tap
autocomplete and let's say that I'm
looking for a particular restaurant this
this one used to be my favorite
restaurant until I started working on
this talk okay so let's say that we want
to fetch its address for example I hit
command enter you can also hit play here
and basically what that returns is just
the address of this particular
restaurant but let's say that I want to
add more fields and I don't know what's
available to me
well graphical has this built in
documentation Explorer on the right-hand
side and again this is reusing the power
of graph QL introspection features so if
we dive into the root query for example
we can see that these are all of the
things at the topmost level that are
made available to us if we dive down
into restaurant you can see this is that
IDL like structure that we were just
seeing where we can take a name argument
or a borough argument and return a
restaurant object so if we return if we
take a look at the restaurant object
these are all of the different fields
that we can query so let's say that we
want to fetch its cuisine and pretty
sure it's Italian cool so let's try
something a little bit more complex
let's say that we want to fetch all of
the restaurants with a name of Subway in
the borough of Manhattan so now because
we're using restaurants plural we're
going to get back a list of all these
restaurants let's say that we again want
to reuse the address and cuisine and now
we get back a JSON response of all the
restaurants of Subway's in man
but if you notice there's some more
information that we can fetch on the
restaurant type for example inspections
and the rent again this is a whole list
of inspection types so let's take a look
at all of the inspections of each of
these inspection has things like grade
when it was created inspected at so
let's say let's get the last time that
they were inspected and maybe the grade
that they received cool so we get back a
z' in most parts bees don't go to that
one and so we get back a of structured
response based on the things that are in
our query we've defined that we're
allowed to have and you can also dive in
to say violations this is where all the
really good stuff is so descriptions are
basically a list of all the violations
that you got in human readable form some
bad contact surfaces
nobody's washing their hands at that one
my spill flies I still up subway ok cool
so let's dive back into keynote there
cool awesome so one of the things that I
was hoping to point out what that live
demo is the idea that you can fetch
multiple resources in one roundtrip so
contrast that to earlier where we had
our desktop client which had to make
numerous requests to numerous endpoints
to build up the full picture of data
that we as a client may need and
contrast that again to the backends for
front-ends model where each particular
device has its own endpoint now each of
those devices can utilize this same one
graph QL endpoint so let's talk about
what it takes to implement a graph QL
server so the NYC restaurant grades
website is just a rails app when we send
a request to slash graph QL we end up at
a pretty regular lookin controller this
controller starts by taking the query
out of the params it's just a plain old
string and it passes us two it passes it
to our schema to be executed once we get
a result from the schema we've render it
as JSON and serve that back up to the
client that requested it but in order to
do all of this we need a graph QL
implementation we need the graph schema
execute part and like sequel there are
many different implementations today I
want to talk about the Ruby one because
this particular application is a rails
app and this is guru Co so the de facto
gem for graph QL is aptly named graph QL
Ruby is created by Rob masago and it
allows us to define our graph QL schemas
in Ruby so let's take another look at
that restaurant query that we were
looking at before and remember that it
has schema definition that looks
something like this it starts off with
the root query at the top the restaurant
field returns a restaurant object and it
has an argument which it takes an
argument named string but what would
this look like in Ruby well let's start
by taking just the top level just the
root query and set aside the restaurant
field to start so it would look
something like this in Ruby you can see
that we define a new graph QL object
type and we set the object's name to
require e this is the DSL of graphical
Ruby it's it's relatively
straightforward now one thing that I've
emitted from almost all of my slides
just for the sake of space is
documentation you can use the
description DSL down on the bottom there
to annotate your schema with various
different descriptions and that's how
graphical was fetching all of its
information on the right hand side in
the documentation Explorer ok so moving
on to the restaurant fields what would
this look like in Ruby well it's a
little bit more complex but let's break
it down step by step we start by
defining the name of the field that's
returned then we have to pass the
argument we define that it must always
be a string and again this is the part
where graph QL can validate that you're
always getting sane input after that we
have to specify the return type and in
this case I'm passing an entire Ruby
object in this case it's the Ruby schema
definition for restaurant because
remember restaurant has a bunch of
fields of its own that it can implement
and finally we have to tell the schema
how to fetch the underlying data and at
the heart of every field definition is
something called the resolver in this
case I'm just calling out to active
record I'm doing a restaurant dot fine
by and I'm passing in the argument that
was passed by the user inside of this
query and so once we get back our result
the schema starts to look for the
restaurant definition and we haven't
defined that yet so let's look at what
that looks like so this is our
restaurant type remember it had at least
name in cuisine both of which return a
string and again we start off by
defining the graph QL objects name we
can specify a description to have it
show up inside of the documentation
Explorer but what about this cuisine
fields which returns a string well again
we start by defining the name of the
fields we return we specify the return
type in this case it's just a plain old
string there's no more selections that
you can make on the cuisine field and it
just returns a scalar value and finally
we have to tell the schema how to fetch
the restaurants cuisine in a resolver
and so in this particular case this
lowercase restaurant is just the active
record object that we got back from the
previous resolver we passed those
through from resolver to resolver until
we end up with the result that we'd like
to have and so this is an important part
that graph QL schemas are composed of
resolvers and while I used active record
in all of my examples that doesn't have
to be the case the data can be resolved
from absolutely anywhere which makes
graph QL a facade it's a facade in front
of your database cache and services and
in this era of micro services that we
found ourselves in you can tuck all of
the complexities of an application
behind this single simple interface and
you get to use your own existing
application code one of the biggest
misconceptions that I hear about graph
QL is I don't want to add a whole graph
data store to my stack that's that
sounds like a pain but that's not quite
what we're doing we're building a query
language on top of your existing
application code and that's what we've
done at github so github as a company is
almost nine years old now the REST API
that our users rely on what we call v3
has been in use of six of those last
nine years and to be honest the API
really hasn't changed that much we add
new resources as new features are
released but we strive to keep the least
amount of change as possible because
every time that we change our API were
to use it we're doing our users a
disservice that means that our users
to update their code because it may be
broken but as you can imagine there's
some pain that comes with supporting a
six year old API so about a year ago
when we started discussing what the next
version of our API could look like we
all had ideas of improvements that we
wanted to make but it wasn't until March
20th 2016 when the original proposal for
graph QL at github was submitted that
the next version of our API really
started to take shape a few weeks later
a proof-of-concept was done and it
allowed us to query for things like
repositories and users the the
straightforward objects in github system
and after seeing this proof of concept
we all started asking each other if this
is what we could do in a matter of weeks
imagine what we could do over the course
of say a year so about a week later a
new team was created to take the
proof-of-concept to and to the next
level and see really how far that we
could get from ql' and about eight
months later where we released graph QL
to the public at github universe it's a
developer conference that we put on in
San Francisco every year and it was an
opportunity for us to get feedback from
our users on this new API and fast
forward to today we actually execute
over a hundred million queries graph QL
queries every day and we use graph QL
both externally through a very similar
endpoint to all of the examples that we
saw today but we also use graph QL
internally we use a gem called graph QL
client which allows us to exchange a
query for these nice pretty ruby objects
so you can do things like restaurant
name restaurant cuisine and what this
allows us to do is co-locate our queries
in our views and our rails views and for
anyone who's familiar with react that's
a pattern that you might be familiar
with we've also invested a lot of time
in tooling one particular gem that my
colleague aren't Ariki in here in the
audience today built is graph QL Docs
and what that allows us to do is take
the results of the instruments
introspection query and put it all in
this nice pretty HTML this is what
builds the developer github.com website
you can see that it showcases all of the
types that we have all of the fields and
it's awaited for us to show all of the
descriptions that we've annotated inside
of our schema
we also practice something called schema
driven development so before with our
REST API new developed new features were
developed for the UI first so take for
example the project board feature was
released about a year ago the way that
that feature would have been built is we
start with say the model then we move on
to the controller and then we have our
view until eventually we have this
feature inside of the UI now after that
we would staff ship it because we're
github errs using github to build github
we dog food the [ __ ] out of the
application and so after we get feedback
on all of the staff ship we might make
it arisians on this feature and then we
release it to the world and so it wasn't
until after that release that work would
start on the REST API but today all new
features are built with graph QL from
the start and what this this allows us
to do is build a truly public API
something that's in sync with our
features as they're released but not
only does this allow us to build just an
API this allows us to build a true
platform something that's shared between
the product engineers at github and our
users our integrators the people that
are building on top of this API so going
back to the question that I asked
earlier what if we wanted to put our
clients first well I believe the graph
QL is one way that we can do that thank
you
[Applause]